the dog g unit was so good remember how
good they weren't good enough to get a
chest piece
get them up oh remember that no i don't
holla
he's going down i don't cause i'm around
i don't know that time chin remembers it
you remember it hunched yeah i hate here
to love it that's the classic
gg unit yeah
go shorty it's your birthday dude that
album
one of the greatest albums of all time
people applause
it was lloyd banks 50 cents curtis 50
cent whatever his name is gunshot wilson
or something
and then who who's the other guy that
was crying on on uh
i recorded it young buck young buck
marbury too i think
young buck was crying yeah was in the
background eating vaseline because he
got older 50 cents
he's going to cut him from g-unit he
started crying he started groveling it
was
it was so bad it was terrible yeah but
that's a tough thing to hear
yeah he on the radio show he's like i'm
going to cut
no he he secretly recorded him on a
phone conversation and he
he's like groveling it was really sad
and he's still
he's still kind of don't worry he's not
killing him oh i'd love to see that
uh-uh i don't want it and was he going
like this i want to be in
the unit
what if he made people stutter it out
when they said it
would help 21 questions dude he had so
many that was the
kids this was that out this is the album
right yeah this is
get richard but that's him that's just
50. dude
i'm patiently waiting for this dude that
album gangster
bro that album look at the hits
high all the time yeah how's that one go
uh
tangerie ellisay
like my style remember freyja before he
got murdered or whatever
oh wankster remember wangster
wanksta sticky you ain't got nothing
bro yeah they're still not good enough
to get a [ __ ] tattoo of them though
i don't care how drunk you were where's
your g-unit tattoo bro i didn't get one
because i wasn't in prison like this guy
[Music]
is the was of nice